MARK: I'm back. What did I miss?
BOB: Uh, Mark, I'm contructing a "Wade soundboard" at the moment.
MARK: oh no..
WADE SOUNDBOARD: Yeah Hey Man Yeah Man Man Yeah Man Hey Yeah Hey Hey Yeah Hey
BOB: Alright I'm ready.
MARK: I'm ready. Let's go!
BOB: You're not ready, you're not-- Oh, you are ready.
MARK: (GIGGLES) Fuck you man!
BOB: I'm sorry. What was that Wade?
WADE: BUHBAAHUARRHBAA
Mark: I thought you were just punching babies. I thought that was your bit.
Mark: Uh huh uh huh, yeah wow okay you're smart, you're smart.
Mark: Uh oh -- People couldn't even see the game on that one!
L-Lixian, what you're gonna have to do--
You're gonna go snatch the vaad from their stream,
put my face cam over their face cam,
And... that's what we're gonna deal with. Okay? cool.
(high-pitched rewind noise)
BOB: Uh, Mark I'm constructing a Wade soundboard at the moment.
WADE SOUNDBOARD: Hey Hey Yeah Hey Yeah Hey Man
WADE: (SOFTLY) Is that what I sound like?
BOB: That's you baby!
BOB: Alright, I'm ready. Ooh the Globox.
MARK: I'm ready.
WADE: "Globox"?
BOB: Whoo, I like Globox.
Mark: What's up with--
wuh-BU-gaaH-BAAH I WAS--
...cracking open mah soda. Sorry hang on everything's fine...
Wade: (MOCKING MARK) WERHBEHGERHGEHERR
Mark: Oh, okay all right, yeah good- good- good impression of me yeah, thanks.
WADE: ARHBBORBOR
BOB: Sorry- I'm sorry. what was that Wade?
WADE: BARRHORBOBARRH-SODA
SOUNDBOARD: barrhorbobarrh-soda
BOB: Oh Goddamnit.
(MARK LAUGHS)
Wade: I'm not gonna repeat myself-- I forget you fuckers have the power to--
SOUNDBOARD: barrhorbobarrh-soda
MARK: I don't-- I don't have that power, but...
I   c o u l d   h a v e   t h a t   p o w e r.
BOB: Sorry, got em.
MARK: NO, you didn't get me. I've got you!
...No, okay, nevermind
SOUNDBOARD: YEYYYAAAH
MARK: Bob you're gonna put my editor out of a job!
This is so good. I just can pick this up raw.
(MARK AND BOB LAUGHS)
BOB: Listen, Everybody needs some of this.
MARK: Listen, I don't-- Oh, you're not gonna f--
you're not gonna pull the wool over my eyes twice. I've got you!
SOUNDBOARD: *airhorns*
MARK: HOW in the world!
Bob: I'm not gonna lie, but I played that zero--
(WADE SCREAMS)
MARK: QUICK CHALLENGE HIM CHALLENGE HIM!!! It--It cant possibly be true.
BOB: There still a way its true right?
WADE: YES!
BOB: Oh there you go.
WADE: I'm one for one on challenges Mark, how you doin' this game?
MARK: Shut. Up! I'll kill ya.
BOB: Hey that's my bit okay? You cant- you cant death threat, that's my bit.
MARK: Okay, I'm sorry. I thought you were just punching, babiess? I thought that was your bit.
I'm just gonna get this out of the way cuz I know it's gonna happen. So wait I want
Wow
One game without screaming at each other
cursing each other out
Episode that everyone hated that we that is one of my favorite things we ever did and nobody liked it
You even drunk why didn't you play a card wait I was busy yelling at my jack wait a minute
I was screaming at them so I could come back and be nice and calm to you
Well, that's unfortunate
Not making this mistake again. Oh
Nice, well played well that what juice bag, it's Globox. I like lo box. It's kind of a big liar
Yeah, do you like these do you like this hand that I have chat isn't it? Amazing?
Hey listen buddy, okay, this don't
Fucking sweet baby agree. Okay, that's not it. Uh, why not?
Okay, that's fine I won't have this hand for very long why wait what huh wait why what's happening
What do you know that? I don't know. Well, I know what's in my head
Apparently everybody has everything holy fuck
We're gonna yell I thought it was gonna be chilly
No, no, no one's yelling, we're calm
I'm chill. Let me chill ma'am. You know, I'm sure we could turn up the volume a bit
That's a nice little pun that I hate Oh
Turn it I laughed at it because I got it I didn't get it
I my brain like I've always realized that you're smart and not a complete. Idiot like you know like a Globox is
You I didn't think it was but now I have a sneaking suspicion that no
I have been told no it never never never was not even the one time
right
Well, right
unnecessary
right
Why why I had to try
Jump, why why? Okay, Bob, you're gonna laugh. I don't know if I'm gonna laugh, but I had to do that
But but I'm not laughing
No, no, I don't think I'm gonna fucking laugh
What I was right wait, you know what what here, you know
you're gonna laugh you are you're gonna you're gonna eat this because it's me, I mean
All right
Okay, well it didn't do any difference I guess so I
only heard you once
No
Well, this is an interesting turn of events that I'm not to Bob gonna laugh is Bob gonna laugh
I think they're gonna laugh Bob. You're probably - laughs
Laughs be like laughs god fucking damn it. I feel like it's unlikely that I'm going to laugh
Bob will kill you want anything but blue
blue so glad you said that here I
Know I would have preferred more jokes in my pants would have preferred not blue
Yes, he didn't he well, you know what? You're right
I just thought as Fred we could've collectively, you know work together something you're gonna laugh because I've got two of these
You know what? You're right
That was creepy you snagged it. Okay. Well you guys are gonna laugh
Yeah. Oh fuck. That's the wrong one. All right, whatever Oh
Purple dragon, why do this?
We're all laughing. Yeah, you know what?
All right, there we go, that's a good one. Maybe why can't I jump in on this
You know what you're right
Yeah, have you never edited your own video it's been a long time I don't believe this all right, I believe this I
Thought I wanted to play this card, but I guess I don't want to play this card please do mind
We're gonna laugh because you're gonna laugh
Oh
Yeah, Bob why pretty funny right mark?
Isn't that funny aren't you laughing?
It's so funny, right
I get it I get why you're always so happy all the time. I get it. Yeah, see that
That head is
Jovial is what that happy. Yeah, and it's actual delight in the form of cards. Yeah, wait, you're gonna laugh maybe god
Laughs you're gonna laugh
I'm kind of glad that I didn't I laughs you know, what?
Fuck all of this. Okay Oh Mike. That's I'm gonna laugh. You're gonna just relax. Oh
The joke's on me for the last that's not what you want to see Bob. Am I gonna laugh? No
Probably not
Okay
I don't have any good jokes, okay
I got Joe quiet. Wait, go go to the market. Wait. I just want to see what you got
I just want to see what you're working
For groceries groceries no to get away from his horrible looking. Hey, whoa, we're being chill everything
Laughing my bro
It was chill man. I was chill
chocolate out, you know
When life gives you some Stinky's you just got to keep it in perspective and chuckle them right out of your system. Yeah, well
Shit back you plebeian piece of ass me thank you. That's that's pretty unkillable
Quit changing the goddamn color why I feel like everyone including Globox is being pretty chill
You know, I'm very chill despite. The fact that there is a spiked dildo going into my asshole right now really well
That's probably against terms. Well, see you kind of did that to yourself? What's funny? You're gonna laugh
You're gonna laugh oh wow. Yeah, that's that's exactly what I was hoping for
Yeah, man
Don't mind me laughing behind my smoke here. Really fun
your your concealed laughter is even more joyous than your actor is the best form of
Education yep, that's the one medication
I like okay
Goddamn turn so that's fine. That's okay mark. Yeah. Yeah, uh-huh
You're gonna laugh you're gonna laugh you're Globox funny that's so funny
No, I think it's I think it's probably Marx that's gonna have to have a laugh
Wait, hey Globox. Listen. Oh
No, hey, well if they're both dreams so Reds not gonna help you. Well, that's unfortunate. How do I not?
Okay. Well that seems so unlikely, you know, it's just funny right sometimes funny
Globox you are gonna laugh with buddy
So many goups on them, you know we vomit in your own mouth and you try to swallow it
That's basically what this hand is like but to my eyes
But Globox didn't play there sevens. All right, cool
But I'm gonna draw some more cards
Is it an impressive hand?
You know like you you're gonna laugh when you impressive who impressive I'm gonna take it right now for myself. Oh,
They drew, okay green it is Green is not a good green green is not a good I can just tell you that greens
Okay, that's what woah box is gonna be laughing if it's green, so just be chill look mark. Yeah clicked it. Okay, never mind
Nothing's gonna happen
Just take that whole I can't believe you didn't challenge wait all that. Wait how many things can you possibly fit inside your asshole?
New place for thing I can fit three sperm whales and
One half of Grandma one half of Grandma you too. Grandma. Well
Wait, you're gonna laugh my dude. Look at that. Oh, this is
Yes, I I think you've got some joy to spread some things to spread. Some of them might be joyous mark do wait
You're gonna laugh you're gonna laugh in my card. You're really gonna laugh
What card what color do we want guys what cause gonna get you to the win as green as the hand
That's the all right, its lowest, okay
Really just gonna hand that to me. Uh-huh. All right. Everyone's everyone's gonna laugh Oh,
What?
Was that weird?
Okay
Mark's gonna enjoy this. I have so many choices. All right, I did it. Oh no
No, that's cool. That's cool. No you see the way you smack that six out there. Yeah, well
I'll be right back. You're gonna laugh gonna get funny. What are you gonna get? I
Don't understand I don't either oh
My god Wade's gonna laugh. Oh cool Wow
It's going to chuckle it up cool. Oh
That's the end
Wait, does that happen you to draw and don't do anything?
Yeah, when you when you timeout you don't get to play but no don't why would you do that to him?
Oh, that's we're gonna he was gonna laugh Globox when you do that to me
Laughs. Oh dear Oh No. Okay well mark
Okay, I'm wearing my cloak sweater, oh wow a glow box you're gonna laugh but fuck you
Whoa, I'm at fudge, you know, why?
That's fine
Hey, come on man. I just I didn't do anything to you. No, it's not at you and mad at the universe
Well, that'll solve all of our problems
Those nine cards you earned it man. You got the extra cards, okay
No age all right. Helm sure that's okay. All right. We did a whole lot there. Oh
Cool um deep calm deep
Breaths from flying up and down the seven flights of stairs in my mansion estate wait, man. You can't afford it Turner. You're gonna laugh
For dinner, but I do live in a ten the billion dollar house in Cincinnati's prime
Place of residence and he lands it way to bring it home with
Just trying to keep it believable, you know, everybody knows about Cincinnati's prime land real estate. Yeah
Everybody does what is it rhubarb? Is that like a turnip?
What's a rubber is a rhubarb, I think that's what you use for safe sex rubber
Baby rubber you got to make sure you have a rubber bright. Mm-hmm. Yeah, that's it
It's actually harvested from a rare
When it cuts you off and it just sounds like you say rubber it's less funny and it's gross. Oh
Dear, hey mark only has one card left. Yeah, the most dangerous game
Box I swear to god. Oh, no, it's okay. You're gonna laugh
Let me laugh
Wow what color you want there Bob uh anything but yellow, I guess I don't know
Just to make you just to make you feel better I don't want anyone to feel like they're excluded, you know, you're right
Thank you all have a lot of cards. I feel like we need to gang up on Globox
That's what I feel like that doesn't help anybody win though
No, but we could just gang up on Globox and it's it'll be it'll be funny. You know, everyone will laugh
Okay. All right. Yeah, we're
You're gonna laugh wait
your box
Won't feel better. Yeah, you know, actually I kind of do those nice fortunate that it ended on yellow. But thank you kind sir
Thank you. Well, I
I'm gonna laughs
Listen yeah, come on then
that's rough a little bit celery bait is not the word you want to use there celery bait sounds like
People made puns. I tried to make a lettuce celebrate. It was lettuce celery bait and celery bait just
It doesn't you know, it rubs me the wrong way weed. You know, you must have been paying it, you know, oh, you know
Hey, listen just because he did it to you doesn't mean he did it on purpose
Okay. Usually I just happen to have a lot of well, I
Have did you have a lot
It was blue once upon a time. You're gonna laugh. Oh, I am gonna laugh mark
How did you even do this? All right, look look man
Did you make this happen look I don't know what
Did not you want to see how funny was let me take a look Pass
Okay
Never mind deal with that problem. Okay, I guess I'll look at my oh, hey my old handbag
You're gonna laugh
You're gonna laugh Bob. You're really gonna laugh with this one you me. No, not laughing
Not me laughing. I am laughing
As they say not me laughing I was laughing
Impossible I just
I could jump in
And we'll never know how many cards well box gets up juice what if you get blue again for like a second
You go back to yellow after that are all right. Well, come on Globox
Hey Marco, me main man. Your green is not one of the colors
You know, what? Wait, I will save you from this fate. Oh
My hand doesn't even load correctly. It's all stack
Take it I guess no, I mean like I can't see
Oh nice
Oh
Whoa, the game is breaking. Oh, whoa. Okay guys, I'll be here. Just leave it right. I've got a plan. Okay. Yeah
Really dig through my deck for that one my plan. Sorry. I wanna I got it
Come on not like this. Well, that's not what you want to see
Well, this is awkward Oh No, but why would you do that for him? Well,
Mark I'm just curious to see how many things you have in your hand
All right, you're gonna laugh but I don't wait. Wait, wait wait. No you have to have I didn't have but
Gosh darnit, oh, well who's laughing now? That's the question
Listen, so I'm just glad I got to do this. I'm really curious. Yeah, you you you want to see this? It's nonsense. Oh,
Okay this it's the colors it consolidates in two colors, I got it I got I
Changed my mind
Okay, fair enough. Hey, wait take a look at that fair's fair. Right wait, um,
Fair is fair. If you're not gonna answer I can answer for you fair's fair
Well
Lo box let me tell you something about hey, you got the head back first fair. I did I did get the handbag actually
I'm glad that's all fair here fair's fair. We're fair friends, and we're fair fair to each other fair is fair
Wait a minute. Hey, Bob. Do you mind this I mean
You don't really give me a chance to answer
Thanks for asking though Oh for fuck's sake I grabbed my mouse at the wrong angle
You're gonna laugh wait, oh dude so funny gonna laugh tell you what dude so
Mm-hmm find the chuckles
I
Just want to keep I just want to be on on-brand. Oh
Here mark, I got you
Homie know what don't thank God. Oh no, I forgot how those worked
Laughs but I say it myself there I've got I've got some jokes don't you worry about it?
Okay, tell them I bet I'll laugh. Well, if you're not gonna let me tell them how am I supposed to tell them a
Visual joke. Do you have to have
It's like a physical
Gag, you know, huh? It's more of a that's a good one. Ha ha ha joke I get it. Yeah. See you got it
Yes, fuck
Mmm-hmm as fuck here. Wait, wait does what what's going on? He knows what's good?
Okay. I'm not I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding
I didn't mean that I didn't mean that how long is this one round been half Oh
Got him, I'll mark out him whatever whatever it's all good. It's all the same. It's all good. It's all good
Oh not green, no not green you're not green
Perfect. Listen
Wait mark, Greene's pretty good. What you want green? Sorry. I got a can't
This isn't even fun have to die but I mean like if you think about it, you might laugh no, no not green
No, wait, no, hang on
Green no, no, no
I don't want to laugh. I can't laughs I've been capable
That's the cool eight you played there and that's thank you going. Well, you know, yeah
No, no, no
You know what Globox you need to calm down a little bit okay bow, whoa hey
You're number one in my book no, wait two fingers to say well
Okay, you've been demoted to fourth in my book several hundred more one's not gonna jump in there Globox. Ah
Got him Bob. You're gonna laugh. I don't want to laugh. I'm fucking well
Bob that wasn't fair. You need it. You need to play Wade. Oh, you're going to laugh
Well, hey man, Wow, oh wow
What well that escalated in a weird direction that I did not anticipate I jumped in
Also, it was my turbo Oh
Sick sick play play. All right. You guys are gonna laugh. Okay. Yeah
You were right that we were gonna laugh oh
You guys you guys are gonna laugh whenever you eventually all
See what happened to this hand that was once in who know Han
Everything's fine. Everything's fine. Laughs
Deep deep deep deep deep breaths. Okay. Well, hey Mark what color it was? I
Don't read maybe I know I'm not done eating please
Damn it. All right, not Reds at all. You lied to me you lied
Stall Wade made a strong counter-argument. What can I do? Oh
Well, you want it you want it you want yeah you want
This let's light this candle, huh? That's light. Oh, look. I don't look how that you know
When this when this game doesn't end in in 13 hours
We're all gonna laugh everyone's go I got a draw, huh
Man drawing has certainly been my strong suit this game. Haha. Oh
That's a good play. That's good play. I got you're gonna laugh done. Are you done punching Wade?
Well answer, that's the strong no mark, I feel like I didn't get to experience your joke the way you would want to know
Okay, I didn't even get a chance to get told a joke. I just got the punch punch lines that straight to the punch. Whatever
Don't don't look at those that's not good. I'm looking. Well. I appreciate you leaving a 5 on there. So I'm here for you
Hey too late
You're gonna laugh
Yeah
You always get it like haven't have a millimeter before I do well, I'm sorry, I'm sorry
I just had blood burn to my place. I got your back Bob. That's what we call a winning hand over there
So just oh it's truly. It truly. Do be like that. Yeah. Oh wait. No. It's
Okay, wait, hang on I can make this I can make this good for you Bob. I could make it good for you
You're gonna laugh
If I do this, then I can make it good for you, right?
Yeah, I was pretty good. I made it good for you Oh God
Pile this up. Oh, no, don't do that
Ten cards hold man. That's funny. Oh, you're gonna laugh. You're gonna laugh. Wow really? But oh,
Wow, well that happens after their disappear
Okay, just please get us out of here I can't take as much humor can we take a government-mandated break you gonna stop laughing
rt
hnmrvb
[Music]
gYou